hello and welcome to this video playing
max power here with white particular
recollection of what I had on the ball
against a couple of games already in
seven games with a plus to score okay so
he plays my line the Zurich variation
and I'm going to play the absolute main
line against it and see what he's doing
maybe he has studied my book and it
tries to find out what I think is best
against it rook e8 I don't play a
looking aid in my eye in my book but
it's not bad solid band off so I can go
III here I think I'll do it's also g3
hmm ok so he played it in a somewhat
more restrained way restraint is just a
bit nicer way of saying in a passive way
we'll see I would see what happens yeah
this is this is looking quite nice for
white just have more space and black
doesn't have a particularly great idea I
think and how to continue wow I didn't
expect that I'm happy that the B file is
opened the a pawn he has a lot weaker
then when any of my pawns so night b3
immediately or not can do that I can't
do that that's nothing huh but it's
difficult for him to keep that anyway
let's make sure that there's nothing
nothing ever happens in the center I'm
not sure about you for when i move the
night away yeah ok but now a 4 is them
is the new weakness
it's very difficult to get f5 in here
I just take my time here then the night
she has two ideas that can go to III or
I can maneuver it to see three but I
think I'll go to e3 having nine f5 as
the reserve one one big issue here is
that simply black has no counter play at
all there are many ways to also snatch
the air for porn but even Queen d1
Bishop c2 as a very serious option okay
i think a root 2 mb 7 is not bad now you
played this rookie 8 version and I don't
like that at all this is some a bit too
passive I believe okay so what now here
many many options the special probably
should be regrouped looking at the age 6
pawn this is an additional idea that
could prove quite useful yep let's cover
this
let's see if I can irritate them a
little bit down on age 6 yeah I managed
so now i have the night regrouping if
desired okay well f5 is this just
weakening I know you cannot actually
play it in the first place
yeah the night here has potential night
to be five and can also just the
technical porn okay yeah let's get on to
the seventh again one big issue is that
in some in many cases I just I just can
trade and this is enough to win because
I will win them a four-point at the end
in many situations okay maybe just throw
pre 600 trading this is not bad as a
force a week I could have played rugby
eight there was useless could have just
won the bishop yeah i was a little bit
too focused on on kind of grinding this
home when i just could have taken
material would have been a lot easier
okay a grind witness also win me so
let's go to c7 snidey a distance idea so
i'm going to get the King involved I
guess this is not bad taking some
squares
okay so let's see get the a pawn going
and the bishop to make voice also kind
of nice mmm it's still a kid not much
right a 6 ok so let's go to this okay so
let's just get everything into place
look here not um advanced or I get the
get the King any nearer and now 95
should should do the trick getting a
beep order should be cool check the yeah
so bishops is seven or what is the
cleanest cleanest way to do it and then
probably a form
it opens its opposite colored bishops
but it's also three passes so don't
think there's much that he can do black
resins gym that wasn't that wasn't a
very nice outing for this line I think
that ruki eight is mostly a waste of
time I think Queenie 785 should be
played immediately ok this is never
totally bad but I think what's black
should avoid is here is this what what
you play it down I'd be seven and so on
this is a bit too passive I think what
black should do it is to play some kind
of c6 either now all of them yeah i'll
start with this may be a try and then
this you have to get some kind of play
and he never did anything here no NOC
five is very very passive v6j five and
after a fiver this is this is very close
to being strategically lost I think
because the a porn is very very weak and
I'm better on the B file so if I'm not
doing something really stupid i think i
should win the game and this is very
nice I actually could have one quick
area with this would be eight business
it also has quite helpful then I know
these positions quite well well I will
do something this is a nice shot given
by the engine check check and this one
the ISS is a very tough line for a human
player the end you win this back you're
not checkmating what you win this bag
with a winning ending
yeah okay but this wasn't bad am getting
the night over now this this is good no
keeping everything and now of course
will be a twin step it should be me
again it was a bit of a silly move but
it is it's a winning ending em with the
with the bishops you can really very
weak you cannot do anything check just
check extremely passive yeah those were
just yeah much to promotion ok I have to
say that this is probably one of the
lines in the names of that I know vest
so it was kind of nice to have that on
the board even though I looked at it
mainly from the black side this is often
so very helpful if you happen to get it
with white now you know the ideas and
quite often you can ya be successful
against your own systems because you
know them in general they are not just
from one particular side ok hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching